ich habe mich gerade erst die schon fünf
standards design gesetzt man geht auf
jeden fall mehr kurse schaut euch
einfach mal meinen händler
[Musik]
und jetzt willkommen beim ein video ich
hoffe euch jetzt gut ich habe mir heute
was wirklich wirklich ganz besonders
überlegt das wollte ich schon immer
machen ich wollte euch einfach mal davon
überzeugen
ich kann das auch und zwar heißt ja
immer neue mobile ist das beste bildung
ist der schnitt 19
ich glaube da hat noch keiner die rechte
mit mir gemacht und zwar bin ich mir
dann hat mir folgendes gedacht alex du
musst auch deinen eigenen jonglieren so
genau habe ich das jetzt noch nicht
durch strukturiert um erst sein
ich weiß nur es bunt werden es soll
außergewöhnlich werden und es soll von
leuten gekauft werden
ich habe mir gedacht so 99 eigentlich
ein guter und fairer preis deswegen
würde ich sagen wie viel los kaufen ein
bisschen was ein und dann wenn sie das
grobkonzept steht laut stadt weiter und
dann wird davon wirklich so ein mengen
produziert also ich muss jetzt erst mal
gucken wie ich das genau an gehe und was
da so alles rein kommt aber ich bin
davon auf jeden fall fest überzeugt ich
glaube da persönlich sehr mich und den
namen habe ich auch schon alex wie also
dass heute wieder einfach mal gedacht
ich jetzt meinen eigenen du schon mal
gucken was bei rumkommt beginnt erst mal
einkaufen und ich hoffe ihr habt ein
bisschen spaß beim zusehen let's go
[Musik]
autofahren
so leicht wird eingekauft
ja wirklich sehr sehr geile sachen dabei
natürlich einmal einen duschraum den
brauch ich weil ich habe keine ahnung
wie man den verstand raubt mir gedacht
ein bisschen blau ist immer gut deswegen
hier so blauen glücks das ganze auch
noch in pink richtig geil dazu komme
noch ein paar kallas ich meine man muss
das ja möglichst auffällig gestaltet
damit das auch gut verkauft und für den
gewissen duft und das gewisse aroma-
einfach mal eine fette zitrone und ich
glaube damit kann ich den markt in
deutschland auf jeden fall erobern
du bist mein bruder ist doch hinter der
kamera und wir müssen jetzt natürlich
erst noch ein bisschen schaue ich hab
mich schon 15 anders design gewährt wie
man sieht ist auf jeden fall mehr cool
geworden als ihr könnt ja meine
kommentare schreiben von eins bis zehn
wie gut ist dieses design also ich würde
auf jeden fall alles geben ich würde
sagen machen in welcher halt einfach mal
feiern mit unseren kirchen bisschen
gemischt und experimentiert und dann
haben wir schon meinen duschen der dann
auch bald auf den markt kommt dass ich
auf jeden fall noch nicht gut
so kann man es nicht verkaufen da ist
muss das zuerst mit ihr war geil einfach
alles das gleiche
schaut euch einfach meinen händler
geil damals kaufte ihr neues amt rufen
bevor wir jetzt hier weitermachen können
wir erst mal ein paar kügelchen rheins
ich habe mir extra dafür wird begrüßt
und was tut man helfen kann man
eigentlich sein dass mit schöne farbe
und wenn klatschen noch kurz die letzten
zahlen seien extrem viele farben waren
einspringen da das ist glaub ich hab
eigentlich vor dass mein produkt auf
jeden fall so blau als marken fahrerfeld
und die schluss kommen und die pin
typischen jetzt besonders denn duster
obendrauf
fast schon alltäglich in den habe und
ich muss ja alle davon überzeugen das
ist gutes kleines aroma obendrauf
braucht man natürlich noch die zitrone
[Musik]
gestern durften genau ist für den topf
das was ich jetzt eigentlich noch
irgendwelche reinkriegen so musst du
schon riechen noch nicht anders geht
sofort weil ich kann meine hände ja
schlecht
erstmalig findet in die kommentare
schreiben
wir kaufen von verkaufen auf jetzt
halten sich einfach fragen bis
verständlich weil fußball mehr ist
möglich und man folgt ausgemacht
damit prämien aber es wird auch wieder
welt glaube ich zumindest natürlich
dieses auto schnell wie möglich ins land
dann wird natürlich auch in manchen von
der mutter als vermisst
wir müssen wirklich eine messlatte für
eine woche
[Musik]
am 1
ist schluss
toll für mich man möchte und alte leute
kaufen wenn du schon mal ein video ring
in der beschreibung welche macht erobern
so abgesehen das ganze war megageil ihr
könnt jetzt überall kaufen ist überall
erhältlich für unschlagbare 9 eur 990
meinen der packung es auch 200
milliliter drin ja vielleicht das wieder
gefallen hat dann hat man auch nach oben
lasse jedenfalls gemacht und wir sind
uns eventuell schon morgen wieder mit
schönen tag hat sein